hier le premier ministre françois
legault a annoncé qu'il prendrait cette
décision finale au sujet des
rassemblements de noël le 11 décembre
prochain
aujourd'hui l'opposition lui reproche
vous l'avez entendu de ne pas respecter
le contrat moral qu'il a conclu avec les
québécois quel rôle l'opposition doit
jouer dans une telle situation j'en
parle avec la chef de l'opposition
officielle
dominique anglade à d'avant-garde
bonsoir bonsoir
alors d'abord au sujet des nouvelles du
jour de ces mesures-là devenu maintenant
obligatoire pour les commerces les
centres commerciaux
c'était la chose à faire et je vous
dirais que c'était la chose à faire on
se serait attendu à ce que ce soit fait
il ya deux semaines déjà
lorsque le contrat moral a justement été
annoncée ce qu'on disait c'est qu'il
fallait que ce soit encadré qu'il y ait
des mesures additionnelles pouvoir
contrôler la pandémie et faire en sorte
que les gens puissent vraiment profité
puis sera en profiter de noël est donc
deux semaines plus tard on se rend
compte finalement il faut ajouter de
nouvelles mesures
je pense que oui c'est des maisons quand
on regarde les résultats on n'a pas le
choix d'agir mais en agitant mais pour
les rassemblements noël dans l'état
actuel des choses on a vu des chiffres
du jour que fournier vous vous à la
place du gouvernement à écouter vous
voyez comme moi les les chiffres puisque
je vous dirais privilégié certainement
des gens qui vont être isolé qui vont
être seuls les tests rapides on en a
parlé à plusieurs reprises on à 1.2
million de tests rapides qui sont
disponibles qui prennent quelques
minutes à faire et qui peuvent être
déployées dans des endroits où on sait
qu'il va avoir des rassemblements
s'apprêtent une manière de faire tester
des personnes qui sont asymptomatiques
mais qui vont aller dans des résidences
ou inversement des gens des résidences
qui vont quitter pour aller dans un
rassemblement
donc il ya des moyens la disposition du
gouvernement ça fait maintenant deux
semaines que l'on dit quelles vont être
les mesures d'encadrement pour nous
permettre d'arriver à noël et il est
malheureusement ils ces mesures la honte
avait retardé jusqu'à aujourd'hui des
mesures mais ce sera certainement pas
suffisant il va falloir que outre chose
également mais maintenant à la décharge
du gouvernement peut-être que en
annonçant ce contrat moral on voulait
conclure avec les citoyens peut-être
qu'il espérait justement que les
citoyens allait baisser cette courbe
pour qu'on arrive à noël et qu'on puisse
et ils t'avaient
contre haas à deux parties bien il faut
qu'il faut que le contrat des citoyens
mais il faut également une
responsabilité du gouvernement est
depuis le début on dit c'est très bien
qu'on disait un citoyen respecté les
mesures sanitaires ce que l'on fait dans
la majorité des cas mais il ya aussi une
responsabilité le gouvernement ça fait
des semaines que nous avons des tests
rapides qui sont disponibles
on est toujours en train de les tester
puis les re tester avant de les utiliser
pour quoi marion notariaux ils sont déjà
déployés vous savez trop triste mais
vous savez que les tests ont leurs
limites ou s'ils peuvent entraîner un
sentiment trop grande confiance
oui mais c'est ce qu'on disait sur les
masques je rappelle c'est exactement ce
qu'on disait sur les masques vont pas
utiliser les masques parce que
finalement ça donne au trop grand
sentiment de confiance
la réalité c'est que les experts se sont
prononcés ce que d'autres peuvent faire
pschitt s'est prononcé sur le fait que
justement il faudrait tester des
asymptomatique et on a des mécanismes
pour le faire donc si toutes ces
questions là pour une que l'on a et on
les a pour la santé publique nous on
pense qu'un lien très étroit beaucoup
trop étroit de la politique et la santé
publique
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on
aimerait d'ailleurs rencontré dr arruda
en commission parlementaire
d'ailleurs le premier ministre a pas dit
non à cette demande d'hier le docteur
arruda non plus le premier ministre a
dit que ce serait une question de
trouver le temps je pense qu'il ya
urgence et nécessité des trajets dr
arruda maintenant quand ça fait neuf
mois qu'on est en pandémie je pense
qu'il est grand temps que le docteur
arruda viennent rencontrer les
parlementaires en commission
parlementaire
on est disponible tous les jours de tous
les jours de la semaine s'il faut on va
se rendre disponible je pense que oui
c'est important parce que aujourd'hui
une confusion des genres avec le
politique avec avec la santé publique
puis je pense qu'il faut vraiment la
santé publique et une réelle
indépendance et on a besoin poser des
questions directement à un auteur à vous
donc je pense que c'est très sain pour
notre démocratie est nécessaire en vue
des prochaines semaines qui s'en
viennent donc vous vous estimez il
faudrait faire ça avant noël absolument
absolument et on l'a dit on l'a demandé
on a dit qu'on aimerait que ce soit fait
avant même la fin de la session et
n'importe quel jour il décide de mettre
de mettre en place cette commission
parlementaire
on va répondre présent c'est une
priorité parce que la session se termine
le 11 décembre
ça irait vite une journée vous suffirait
pour l'interroger est passé
c'est pas suffisant une journée mais
c'est déjà un bon début au moins son est
capable de poser des questions par
rapport aux tests priorités qui vont
être faites dans dans les résidences de
comprendre comment les décisions ont été
prises jusqu'à présent de comprendre
comment édition vont être prises au fur
et à mesure pendant temps des fêtes on a
plusieurs questions à poser c'est normal
c'est le rôle de parlementaire de faire
et encore une fois il ya eu aussi la
responsabilité de la santé publique de
se dissocier du politique et de pouvoir
répondre à ces questions là c'est à dire
en temps de pandémie j'imagine que c'est
pas facile pour les gens de l'opposition
de naviguer entre parce qu'il faut à la
fois appuyer le gouvernement tout en
restant critique évidemment est ce que
vous voyez un rôle plus constructif
auprès de la population justement dans
ce contexte extraordinaire vous voulez
je pense justement qu'on était on a fait
au delà la novation n'a fait au delà de
vingt propositions au gouvernement
on a beaucoup entendu la voix d'un
entrepreneur dans toutes les régions du
québec qui vous demander de l'aide
directe qui nous fournissait
d'information pour nous dire on nous a
oubliés alors à plusieurs reprises on
s'est fait le porte-voix aussi de
personnes dans le milieu de la santé
dans le milieu de l'éducation qui
justement demande du soutien du
gouvernement
c'est notre responsabilité le fait mais
d'année des propositions qui sont
constructives et je pense que dans les
dernier dans les derniers mois c'est ce
qu'on a su démontrer si la vive
opposition très concrètes pour le
gouvernement
je vous pose des questions au sujet de
la vaccination vous a peut-être vu leur
sondage ipsos radio canada qui montre
qu'une majorité de gens là redoutent
d'éventuelles a fait son mandat que plus
de la moitié attendrait plusieurs mois
deux heures plusieurs mois avant de se
faire avec c'est comment s'y prendre
pour les rallier ces gens là je pense
que c'est vraiment la science de la
pédagogie vraiment expliquer expliquer
la situation ils vont voir aussi au fur
et à mesure de ce qui va se passer c'est
qui va avoir des en gros ça va être
déployé les gens vont constater la
situation pour pouvoir se faire une tête
mais il n'y a rien de mieux que de
communiquer l'information de dire
d'expliquer aux gens quels sont les
risques
voilà comment ça se passe ailleurs voici
ce que la science nous dit aujourd'hui
pour cette communication là elle est
essentielle pour que chacun puisse
prendre la pleine mesure de ce qui se
passe puis évidemment il avoir des
groupes qui vont être priorisé à cause
la passion plus générale ou parce qu'ils
travaillent dans des milieux plus
difficile alors je pense que les gens
fouillent la maison pour le constater je
suis un guerrier de mieux que la
communication de la transparence en ce
genre de choses une dernière question
plus personnelle qu'allez vous faire
vous pour les rassemblements noël alors
je le dis j'ai le privilège d'avoir
trois enfants avec mon conjoint alors on
va rester notre cellule pendant toute la
période des fêtes on peut rester à cinq
et on va fêter on va fêter noël noël à 5
sinon je vous souhaite de joyeuses fêtes
à vous je remercie madame anglade à voir